es ist die geschichte vom renk bar und
seinem bach meister
seit über 200 jahren schon mitglieder
der familie haas zu diesem wilden bach
am abhang des pilatus
[Musik]
und die menschen am fuße dieses berges
können dankbar sein für wären
aufmerksamkeit
warum das mit der beute einem gebiet zum
das gute note wahrscheinlich wirklich
stadt luzern und kriens horw lebt wird
wasserstoff wird ein pirat dieser so
schnell
und wenn das nicht richtig auf seine
reifenprobleme staaten das rettung
nehmen
[Musik]
werden den hass der bach meister ist
zusammen mit seiner frau priester
unterwegs nach oben richtung pilatus
jetzt fordern reiche quelle um am
rankbach modul hat verschiedene frank
mantek
dort gleich unterhalb der felsen oder
renk noch jung ist wollen sie heute
ihren kontrollgang beginnen
wenn wir dort verstorben könnte auch der
bach habe und sich unter vereint mit dem
band saalbach und nokia oberlibbach
heißt
also wir laufen nicht auf da waren die
funktion wie man da unbedingt auch noch
vor großen spielen wir kontrollieren und
ich habe die meisten orte wirklich okay
wander rad beim monitor ist gerade das
nicht abstürzen der engpass ist ein
heimtückisches gewässer weshalb man
keinen aufwand gescheut hat seine
zerstörungskraft einzudämmen
700 bach verbauungen sollen den wildbach
themen und bach meister werner haas
kontrolliert jedes jahr
ob all die bauwerke noch
funktionstüchtig sind es geht steil
bachabschnitt objekte heiko sind nicht
ganz aber auch für meinen geschmack zu
spät vor box die letzte lauf und da muss
man wieder recht klar ob und wann ein
phänomen und wieder zurück aber es ist
einfach schlecht förderlich direkt am
bach machen aber zu wasserfällen oder
zwischen es sind anstrengende
kontrollgänge meist in unwegsamen
gelände
[Applaus]
die drei niveau chaotisch
das leitwerk durfte sie habe er seine
große chance grad macht welches hohe
schutzniveau der wachtmeister und seine
frau leisten hier eine beschwerliche
arbeit damit die menschen unten im tal
in kriens luzern auch bei einem schweren
pilatus gewitter ruhig schlafen können
wenn man das so etwas kriegt weiter
gedanken warum auch mit der sache da ich
die kupplung leute aber auch die nötige
und da sehen wir dass nur das rinnsal
aber das ist 100 frucht und da habe ich
meine vita innerhalb von einer stunde
meter an hauben abstiege die wie man den
fluss sommer weiß da bringt die
feiertage hof verlassen fünf tagen
hektisch da bringt relativ verlassen und
genau wie die nyt und darum muss
eigentlich immer auf eine mehr oder
weniger höchststandes rechnete vor wie
vor wenigen wochen hat werner haas im
uferbereich des rankings risse entdeckt
gezeigt dass kleinwagen sag mal vorab
krippe und polens am gambacher branche
ihre wer weiß was da mit dem hof der
bach meister wird den berg hier im auge
behalten müssen
ein problem hang oberhalb der straße
beim schweren unwetter im jahr 2014
rutschte der berg talwärts richtung
rheinbach der geologe beate keller
besichtigt mit einem mitarbeiter die
umfangreiche sicherungsmaßnahmen die
danach notwendig wurden
steinschlag und der moore ein museum ihr
held rutsche brehm rainer material event
der orangerie
das wird flüssig und gut noch was los
und wenn das ist bachbett der rückstand
der definitiv das problem das wir
eigentlich weniger wasser und denn wenn
es nur daumendrücken technisch fertigt
der wortlos noch gewaltiger wütete der
renk ag im jahre 1738 eine eigentliche
katastrophe war es auf der holzbrücke
zeigte geologe die damalige abfluss so
jedes rheinbachs vorstand gewaltige echo
war mit vorstellung mit das trio um die
cd einiger bröcker dass sich moore einer
brücke unsere findling aus der modernen
musik sehen was da auf eine gewaltige
schlagkraft entwickeln oder männer die
mit schreibt luzern und der pilatus mit
seinen wilden bächen eine nachbarschaft
die sich im jahre 1738 zur katastrophe
auswuchs
eine unscheinbare trafen erinnert in der
luzerner innenstadt an die damalige
überschwemmung rund 1 meter 60 hoch
stand das wasser
die halbe stadt war überflutet kirchen
und plätze im stadtzentrum um den
heutigen bahnhof waren betroffen
der ring bach in seinem begradigten
unterlauf es ist die eigentliche
problemzone dieses wildbach beim
unwetter im jahr 2014 wurden hier große
stücke der uferverbauung mitgerissen
immerhin die schutz banken hielten stand
ein überlaufen richtung luzern konnte
verhindert werden
das problem mit dem musiker aus 100 bis
300 euro liegt
da ich mich als zweite spitze neben wird
es 670 ereignis wo bereits tolle der
bach versucht hätte er die fußfessel und
die das alter bach bei dem der richter
zeiher navarro der pilatus den alpen
vorgelagert bildet für anrollen die
gewitterfronten eine fatale barriere das
problem oder im bauch ist natürlich dass
sie zurück gebiet am fuß von piraten
sachen verstaut audi electric ge und
daheim ihr umfeld wie höhe für die
niederschlagsmengen mass sofort aus dem
staub
unweit von hier hinter einem wald
streifen lied der ruf der familie haas
der bach meister familie seit 1679 lebt
und arbeitet die familie haas auf dem
lenkerhof etwas oberhalb von
und seit 200 jahren schon mitglieder
dieser familie zum ring bach zu diesen
unheimlichen nachbarn der hier zwar
unsichtbar bleibt doch dessen rollen bei
einem gewitter bis hierher zu vernehmen
ist meine worte hören wir natürlich oben
rutschen oder steigt er war mehr in der
dmg vierter wurde wach aber auf land und
der fahrer man natürlich immer drin und
ich spürte man den rucksack man
eigentlich was tagtäglich logo maria
innen und die sie zum schluss wenn es
dann richtig wehtun gekürzt oder ist ja
da war ich mir deshalb ist ein schöner
slogan 500 meter 35 jahre lang hatte
zuvor werner haas senior den bach im
auge behalten
die sich natürlich vor du hast wohl hat
schnitt von 23 ist der vielleicht die
nächsten tage ist so angesagt aber ein
paar tage möglich als lokale geblieben
im wald oder abbestellen grossraum
zürich nehme der auftritt live
ich habe wenigstens bruder vom rhein
aber wir würden ja das ist schon so
einige der aygo und wenn man selbst mal
in der woche kommt und vorher mitteilen
diese ruine wundertüte also überhaupt zu
beschmutzen oder moratorium muss man
auch enttäuscht dass markt verlieren
einigung noch keine bewohner ein anderes
hinterher zu der vater ist jeweils mit
leidenschaft losgezogen all die jahre
den bach entlang nur ungern hat er das
amt altershalber aufgegeben
wenigstens ist das bach meisterhand in
der familie geblieben
der sohn fährt heute alleine bergwärts
der kontrollgang wir ihn an diesem tag
nicht in gefährliches gelände führen und
auf der strecke um ritter sendern 14
waren ins tor
denn die beste wo sich opera buffa mit
einem tabu die ende bestimmt und der
stromausfall
er brachte oder ganze spezielle
schumacher clubmeister und da bringt
praktisch das ganze jahr 346 kg ist ein
auf kipp und so warten 14
der kauf des titels sei der bub ich
material oktober braucht man aber dass
da überhaupt ist ein buch habe wegen
ihrer oft jedes jahr ist der bach
meister rund 50 stunden unterwegs am
berg dann wenn es die arbeit auf dem hof
zulässt
beim zusammenfluss von zwei bächen
entdeckt werner haas schäden in der
ufermauer
diese droht einzustürzen
die vorräte sind nun mal gut 35
zentimeter für gedrückt
warum der dankbar vorraber mit der
unverwässert was passierte geltung
bomber und die obere später nach und ein
junge die anderen unternehmer davon
fertigmachen damals sofort reparieren
ganz zuoberst hat man besonders viel
beton in den bachlauf gepackt brachial
erscheint hier das menschenwerk
doch offenbar muss es so sein schicksal
oktober nächste pilatus sehr steil
meine gewitter sehen natürlich die
wassermassen der abschlussrunde und wenn
man dann da bach mit der oberschule
verbunden dass kempowski ufer doppel
ebit das über das truck schließlich
scheint ein tal untergang und das kind
gegen astra brocken war natürlich stark
gefördert und das war natürlich
schneller als überlaufen und das tut
natürlich summieren wenn man die
oberlippe vorbeugen und haben wir um das
problem und miriam märk wenn man runter
verbogen und bringt nun sogar süper lig
[Musik]
und da hat der pilatus felsen die alt
wohnen
bei schönem wetter ein beliebtes
wandergebiet 1350 meter über meer
wir haben über dem mittelland
hier beginnt der renk barcas harmloses
plätschern das rinnsal wie verwunschen
liegt das bewaldete quellgebiet auf
seinem weg nach unten versammelte
rankbach von links und rechts noch
weitere 30 gewässer elf quadratkilometer
groß ist sein einzugsgebiet ein ganzes
system das seit jahrhunderten den
menschen sorgen bereitet nachdem der
lenker sich durch das schmale rankings
gezwängt hat
ergießt sich das wasser in die kleine
emme welche das entlebuch entwässert
auch dies einfluss
wer ein beträchtliches
zerstörungspotenzial hat im jahr 2005
war es wieder einmal soweit die kleine
emme überschwemmte den ganzen tag oben
900 menschen mussten damals entlang des
flusses evakuiert werden
die schäden beliefen sich auf 180
millionen franken
es kommt mir hier
dr
an den wänden im hergiswiler
ingenieurbüro hängen fotos vom unwetter
2014 aus der lenk bach über die ufer
trat und stücke aus der ufermauer riss
in der sprache der fachleute ein
70-jähriges ereignis peter scheiwiller
ist zusammen mit seinen kollegen der
ingenieursfirma schubiger zuständig für
die zähmung von 100 wildbächen in der
zentralschweiz darunter auch der ring
bach der mit 700 sperren ganz besonders
in schach gehalten wird
das restrisiko blieb deutlich und es hat
natürlich immer wieder als auch bin
rankbach ausgestattete figuren und
darüber sind wir nicht ganz geordnet
dass ich heute soll das ist als
gesellschaft lebe was 1 300 jähriges
ereignisse im fall des renntages
bedeuten könnte zeigt die karte halt
luzern wurde überschwemmt
das schadenpotenzial ist ein motto von
rang braucht wenn man wenn man täglich
strukturen und entsprechend ist aus
augenmerk sehr stark auf dem rand auch
wie er hat ein riesenpotenzial blüht
wurde im süden das luzerner in einer
chronik vor dem ja es ist natürlich kein
so also wenn mich natürlich über kroate
im internet die sind 60 und der wehr hat
das eigentlich in ein hauptkabel es ist
mir klar es wird er kommuniziert sie im
großen rahmen
im durchschnitt haben ein zufluss des
renntages stecken arbeitet in schlamm
senior peter scheiwiller überwacht die
reparaturarbeiten eine schadensmeldung
des bach meisters hat zu diesen
veranlasst
aber durch marketplace war ich also
fragen die die holz sperren sind bereits
beim meter 2014 beschädigt worden
jetzt müssen sie ersetzt werden 20 30
jahre sollten sie dann wieder halten
die arbeiten werden vorangetrieben denn
in den kommenden tagen ist mit
schlechtem wetter zu rechnen
die schwierigkeit ist eigentlich immer
das wort da sag ich also im sudan mit
dem hut oder ist ein top-team und ja das
ist eigentlich die größte
schwierigkeiten es ist ende oktober ein
ruhiger sommer was für den bach meister
die gefürchteten gewichtigen rheinbach
so schnell anschwellen lassen sind
dieses jahr über den pilatus
hinweggezogen
und doch macht der berg werden haus
einige sorgen
denn er rutschte in großen schüben
richtung bach beliebig select herz
besitzt
fotos 3 meter 25
das tor verschoben ganze baumgruppen
stehen schief auf einer fläche von zehn
fussballfeldern ist der wald in bewegung
geraten
die ursache zu viel wasser im boden
letzten hang ableiten
überall ist die erde aufgerissen
und immer mehr lastet der bergbau
kauften bau sperren
dass ich oben der perimeter 70 oder flug
über kreuz stickoxid medizin rücken die
baumaschinen oberland rücke die steuer
index jetzt so baumann drückt und die
armee riese dort jetzt auch alle
oberland 100 größe und diese interviewt
armselig an zu spät nämlich separat
pauli sind oberland und irgendwelche
vorproduziert web tableau ganze bestürzt
und so wird bach meister wenn er es die
nächsten monate immer wieder hoch
steigen um festzustellen wie brenzlig
die lage ist damit die menschen am fusse
des pilatus keine böse überraschung
erleben müssen
unweit vom rankbach stürzt der giessbach
talwärts
auch dieser wildbach am pilatus gegen
dessen zerstörerische kraft kämpft seit
jahrzehnten der bauer peter ott denn der
bach reist immer wieder stücke von
seinem land weg
es ist ein einsamer kampf und überdies
ein verbotener sagen die behörden
deshalb sieben eigenwilligen man schon
dreimal ins gefängnis steckt wie damals
im jahre 1995 nach acht tagen im
luzerner zentralgefängnis kampeter ort
wieder frei
im verein ist habe ich daheim noch eine
vereinzelung radio lose zieht die klasse
mit duschen rasieren also wie in europa
12 bagger hat die polizei in all den
jahren bei bord beschlagnahmt
doch peter orth kämpft weiter schreibt
eingabe um eingabe wird sich mit
unermüdlicher hartnäckigkeit für eine
sache hier ausgerecht betrachtet erkannt
für nicht für mehr macht und bis zur
oberen ich vermute aber das war mir
gehört zu dem ort ruhiger und das wort
ich als mr
[Musik]